well congratulations on the cast that
you were able to ask you for between us
now you have teh digs julia stiles
melissa george and david harbor now we
understand that Tate digs was one of the
first right of the fort yeah yeah those
of those four so once we kind of had
regrouped and recalibrated the film to
be a low-budget in micro budget film we
then went back to the agents and
managers and said you know hey it's same
script so you know because that's always
the hardest thing is getting them to
read your script initially you know that
can take years time to do but once once
it's they've read it and they're in the
system and they know that other actors
like it you know then you can then it
doesn't really matter so much what the
budget is because at a certain level
actors aren't going to do these films
because they're making 20 million
dollars I mean doesn't matter who's
directing it they're making it you know
an actor who wants to do a dramatic part
or a dark comedy part you know is doing
it because of the part and because they
want to break from the other stuff
they've been doing so whether they've
been TV actors or feature actors or some
combination if they can afford to do it
it could be 0 it could be 65,000 it
doesn't really matter they're doing
because they want to do it so so then
that kind of narrows the pool down a
little bit but there's still a lot of
actors out there can afford to spend
three weeks on a shoot or longer doing a
fun little project or media project you
know so of those yeah Taye Diggs came on
board first and you know was a real
trooper other actors came and went and
you know we thought we had this person
or that person whatever and tay really
stuck with it and he you know I think I
think the material really kind of spoke
to him personally in a lot of ways you
know he he has a young son he's married
he's dealing with sort of questions of
authenticity versus finance and thing as
an actor and as an artist himself so I
think there was a lot about the script
that really
hit home with him so he really committed
to it and then you know and then he
really helped us cast the other parts I
mean this is something I really told
anyone about but you know he was kind of
our shadow casting director I mean you
know you're had approval you know over
the other actors because I said look man
you committed first you you earned the
right to help me decide who gets who
else gets to be in it he's a cool you
know I think I think actors really
respect you more when you when you give
him that opportunity you know and and
also his agent was very instrumental in
helping us find the other actors too and
in fact yeah pretty much all four of the
actors came from the same agency in
three of them came from the same agent
which is somewhat coincidental but also
you know once they have one person in
they have a stake in making it
successful so they work hard for you so
yeah and then but a lot of it is luck
you know you well then it look it's more
than luck it's it if you have enough
money to set a start date you set a
start date and this is something I
learned from Robert Altman like he would
do this on his films and even have these
big ensemble cast but and he was Robert
Altman you know but he always knew he
could get a good cast but even on my
level because we had I because I've been
meeting with actors / literally years I
knew that we would always get good
actors I didn't know exactly who we
would get but I knew they would be good
and I knew some of them would be a
little famous to you know because we
were getting a lot of those people
particularly with the women roles
because there are fewer women roles you
know that are good in Hollywood and
there are way more actresses than there
are actors think about you know any high
school drama program you've been in how
many more girls are there than boys so
you know you do the math and especially
you get to a certain age level you know
in the 30s you know there aren't that
many guys but there's still a lot of
women a lot of well-known winning and
who don't get good parts so if you have
good parts for them and we had kind of
be in doing the adaptation we had
actually beefed up the two women roles a
little bit compared to the original play
so I always knew we would get great
actresses for the women roles
and.and great actors for the guy parts
as well so once we add Tay I knew you
know we set a start date and then and
you kind of have to have balls of steel
when you do this and say look I don't
know who the actors are going to be but
we're going to have four people in here
shooting so let's start prepping our
camera and finding locations and doing
everything else you need to do to get
ready and you stick to that date and
then as you get closer the agents and
the managers they get nervous they're
like wait a minute you know you're about
to shoot wait can I actor be in this can
I actress be in this and they start
fighting over you because actors app or
a vacuum like if they have a vacuum in
their schedule and we were shooting in
May so that's around a lot of TV
hiatuses so there were a lot of people
available in part of is finding the
right schedule that that's good for that
and agent hate it when actors are
calling them like do I have my next part
you know I'm not doing anything next
week what am i doing next week what am i
doing next week so so they love to you
know so if you're within a few weeks of
shooting you can actually you have
access to a much higher end level of
people and your turnaround times like
okay can I give you a script and they'll
read it overnight you know everything
accelerates the whole casting process
accelerates you can make three offers in
a week or four offers in a week and then
by the end of the week you know exactly
you've got so and part of it is you have
to have faith in your ability that
you're going to have luck so with Julia
Stiles this is the best example you know
she had always been kind of floating
around in our lists for four years but
we always thought well she's always
booked up she's always busy we would
have access to her for whatever um and
so her agent called me one day there was
the same age in his taste so I knew him
and he knew the material well he said
are you interested in Julia I said yeah
but she's she's booked in a needle a
beaut play that's supposed to play on
Broadway for the next five months
haven't they been rehearsing for the
last month he said yeah they're
financing fell through two hours ago we
have nothing for her for the next five
months and no Hollywood film is going to
sort of cast her you know for the next
two weeks so are you interested I said
yeah of course under the script 24 hours
later she calls me off her said she's in
so you know part of that is preparation
knowing also that you know I knew her
manager not just her agent her manager
was also
fan of the script because you know three
years before I had taken him out for
breakfast in Venice you know so we've
been working on these relationships for
years so that when an opportunity does
come up like oh okay everyone on teams
any want everyone on our team has
already read the script you know so you
don't have to wait 40 now the manager
has to read it now the agent miss Reed
it's like no no now we just need to wait
for her to read and she did right away
and she was in so you know I like to say
it's almost like finding an actress at
their most vulnerable emotional moment
and just kind of swooping in but um you
know a similar thing with melissa george
she came up the first day I met her was
the first day of rehearsal walking into
my kitchen you know and of course we
rehearsed for two weeks in my kitchen we
couldn't rehearse in the garage because
this was the pre-production office so
and then David Harbor had always been
kind of floating around the various
lists and stuff because he was in the
original play and and actually then from
that play got cast on Broadway in Who's
Afraid of Virginia Woolf got a Tony
nomination for that he's been in
countless movies TV shows he's on the
newsroom now so and obviously he knew
the part you know better than anyone and
I'm sorry tell me again how Ted digs
originally heard of the project yeah so
this I was in park city that year yeah
everything kind of comes back to being
involved with Slamdance and this is this
is another good reason why we start what
kept Suleiman is going and he's because
it's a good way to kind of reconnect
with everyone in the industry every year
whether you've got a film going or not
so I was in that I was in park city and
this agent was a finance agent from ICM
their little indie film finance repping
division and it's got peter trinh who
you know we had talked to about the
project about between us two years
before you know in the first incarnation
but you know I'd stayed in touch with
him and he was in Park City say hey dan
can you buy me a drink like you betcha
you know come up to slam dance I'm sure
we have free liquor somewhere yeah and
so and he was like oh wow you've got you
you know he didn't know that we had
already raised his money through
crowdfunding and had a start date and it
was like oh you guys are really going so
he didn't raise us any money I should
talked about
but he called a buddy of his who was a
junior agent out of the New York office
and like emailed in the script I think
like as soon as he walked out of the
room because the next day I got a call
out of the blue from his agent this
talent agent at ICM saying hey I just
read your script and I loved it and it
was still to this day it's still a
little bit of a mystery how he got the
script I think he got it from this guy
peterborough hundred percent sure and um
and he's like how do you like to meet
with Taye Diggs on Tuesday I was like
okay that he's so weren't you in a
minivan or somebody occasions oh so I
see call me the next day is that I love
the script that's a terrific he's like
can I send it to some actors or
something like I said yeah and then the
app and the next day we were in a
minivan driving because I Drive to park
city every year it's just more fun
always with a bunch of friends of mine
we take that the family minivan and for
whatever reason we got lost this year we
wind up heading east instead of south so
we were on our way to Colorado I took a
wrong turn in heber city which I've
never done before but I've never gone
through heber city before anyway and in
the middle of Utah yeah I get a call
back from this agent saying damn I've
shown the script around now to a couple
of the other agents that we all love it
now and and are you interested in teh
digs and there were these you know other
filmmakers in the car with me a couple
of them were women I just like it what
are you guys think at a gig smell like
swooning back oh hey I did you know and
I like yes I I'd love to meet with today
and then on Tuesday like yeah three days
later I was meeting with him and he was
in you know but yeah at the time he
thought there were three other people
that were going to be in the cast and
they progressively all dropped out and
then we got other people so
you